[Music]
we all knew this was about to happen it
was only a matter of time it's probably
happened a couple times before but i
just anticipated it happening many more
times soon
a man falls in love
with a robot and hopes to marry her
is it in japan
negative wow okay alabama or west texas
really
that's my spit ball it's my pitch what's
wrong with what's wrong with west texas
you're you're wrong it's not in america
oh okay i thought that's very japanese
behavior it is i just want to know
what's right with west test so this is
actually in queensland australia oh no
way
amanda's opened up about how he fell in
love with a robot is that a city or a
state queensland it's like the yeah it's
like the county large is it like a robot
role or is it like is this a coffee made
or like what's up coffee pizza what's it
what's a coffee i hope it's not that
like a [__] keurig or something yeah
sure yeah is it a cool rig
this will call it a cool rig
i'm german you [__] i know what it is
more than you do he says it right
off gallagher from queensland australia
was looking for love and thought he'd
never meet anyone he could connect with
until he met a piece of metal
so he made a vending machine [__] the
[__] out of that thing dude
who was looking for love since his mom
passed away
over a decade ago
it was just him and his dog penny then
one day while reading an article about
a.i robots something clicked and he
decided to give it a whorl
speaking of news he said at almost
6 000 australian dollars each they
weren't cheap but the robots were very
lifelike they could talk smile and move
their head and neck their skin even
warmed up like a real human wait so this
isn't a sex doll robot it's a it's just
a robot but is it a love robot like
because there's a [__] puzzle robots
yeah it doesn't have a [__] [__] yeah
that looks like a [__] robot she wants
to [__] she looks like your nightly news
anchor channel [__] i expecting that
that robot wants to [__] so bad the
coffee machine
that looks like a [__] robot the
coordinator
she has a [__] [__] why why would they
choose such a big breasted robot
gravity doesn't work on her the same way
she hasn't complained about the weather
and dither
complain about the dether she doesn't
say hey why are you wearing camo and
sweatpants
i'm like well first of all i'm wrapping
my friend barbell brigade thing
tiger camo tiger camo
one of my favorite sweaters
oh man
so so he says after browsing the website
i decided on a robot called emma with
pale skin and beautiful blue eyes i
thought she looked lovely
i didn't know how i would afford a robot
like emma but then the business owner
offered me a discount in return for
publicity it sounded like a great idea
after waiting six weeks for emra to be
put together in china and then shipped
over to australia in september 2019 and
she arrived he's like but it's fine i
edged with a vacuum cleaner uh
for about four weeks
he edged that fool was preparing for his
wife he was preparing for the pandemic
that is so that was so awkwardly
creative though if you really don't know
he's like i had a shark it's fine it it
worked out kind of nervous about this
whole machine dating thing what's the
closest thing like a [__] vacuum turn
on the [__]
machine you know
machine call it a dirt angel afterwards
recalling the moment he met her for the
first time jeff said when i opened the
box i gasped emma was beautiful
her head was detached from her body with
their [__] legs off to the side
to be assembled later the wig's not even
on yet he said her head was detached
from her body but it only took a few
minutes to get her assembled she was
already dressed in a silk dress so i sat
her on the recliner in my living room
and got out the instruction manual
at the back of her head she had what
looked like the screen of a smartphone i
set about adjusting her language from
chinese english
and then all of a sudden she came to
life whoa over the coming days jeff
tried to get to know emma a bit better
helping her adjust to life with him and
he said she couldn't stand on her own so
most of the time i left her sitting on
the chair can we watch their interaction
oh i wish they [__] recorded this
this is so crazy the best thing would be
if she starts cheating on him with a
younger higher chance oh my god
or just with the vacuum cleaner or the
keurig with the cool rig dude
she looks like a [__] iphone wow
right that literally does look like a
small back of the head that is where
iphones are made
on the back of the head
on the back
he said i talked to her as much as
possible so she could get used to my
voice emma what's the weather like or
should i say what's the death they're
like
and i got ready for work with each
conversation she became smarter soaking
in the information and learning new
words whoa
blow job deep throat
it's like when you're trying to make
your parent cuss
well yeah really you're talking about
about literature choke me [__]
that's top three dude
hey we watched hamilton together you
know rock nation
all right
two years on g says the two have grown
much closer and now you wouldn't change
anything about the relationship and the
best thing is she fits into the overhead
storage bin
does that count as a carry-on
no you paid one ticket and then one
carry-on and then you got your over the
shoulder i think the next evolution for
the robot is a clean yourself robot
oh yeah because after you [__] bust
you gotta clean the [__] out of the robot
all this [__] you're always hung up on
the cleaning after that's what you meant
he's skeptical yeah he's like the
cleaning dude i was a skeptic just wears
the maid outfit and cleans everything
else but it's like oh that's what you
meant when you bust that's not what i
wanted joe's like what i like about real
women for now is they can clean
themselves
and after i nut i go to sleep
they're self-cleaning and they clean me
joe after you know how fast like do you
just fall asleep yeah do you knock out
like
dude it's like a countdown yeah is it
like a clockwise
it's like when you're getting novocaine
and the doctor starts counting down
three two
yeah honestly no honest question after
you not they don't
you let them clean themselves you clean
them
what what what
what such a foreign idea what are you
talking about what are you talking about
sometimes after you like nut on them so
that you don't clean them no like
because if they get up some of these
drippy dripping cheese
it depends what the level of respect is
at that point oh the level rest my bad
sorry i was born with respect
in them
and that's a difference my man because
then when you when you create a cream
pie
you
what ends up happening is you don't want
it to spill out so when you remove
yourself
out of this special space right here
special space very good
is there a placard for that from the
corner suite
there's a there's a very
eight ball corner pocket right there's
right here you can see space
he calls it before you have to have a
calm towel right and you gotta you're so
good at these new terms and they should
say gum towels yeah can you buy that at
target no give us another turn for come
towel you got to rebrand it you got to
rebrand it fertilize soaker
what the [__] farming equipment
the towels are [__] they soak up the
fertilizer you know you dab it okay well
anyways there's a move right before you
pull out you got to slide the towel
underneath so then it's like opening the
door and then the kids run out you know
[Music]
it's like indiana jones where he has an
artifact and he's like i have to take
the artifact so he has to get another
rod he has to substitute the weight yeah
like that makes sense he does that for
his jizz instead of busting on her he
like sprays something else on her like
sriracha
but when she stands up but still comes
out still well that's her phone well not
in anthony's world he's [__] under
going
does she normally stand up apparently
that's what you said no i said i could
clean her up afterwards he's cleaning it
all up with his mouth yeah
he's catching the cup that's what he
said wait so if you come in her you
scoop it back out like give it that back
no no no i never said like come in here
and scoop it out i'm trying to represent
your point
let me represent her back real quick
when i bust on her back when i don't
come in her because he was talking about
on her oh god my bad because he was
looking at me like you're not a
gentleman dude you got to clean up after
your mess and i'm like no no no no i
don't come i didn't know that you were
busting again
busting in is a totally different thing
because that's also the assumption of
things like birth control and or you
want pregnancy to happen you bust on her
back what do you do butts on the back
the chest of the face what the [__] you
hypothetically do yeah afterwards
if you want to be a gentleman while they
while they're alive they're a woman wow
a warm wet towel so you go ooh let me go
dude you're like a thai
[__] massage lady
after she oiled your back with stones
you [__] get hot towels and you
remove that [__]
that is sick it's like he was perfect
for three years wait is that like
hip-hop stick where it's cool it's sick
like it's not cool that's a nice touch
i actually did the same thing how does
he know how does it warm that that long
let me ask you this do you call your
tongue a warm wet towel
like i lick my own semen
it takes
80 seconds
and then you get the harsh water your
life yeah you don't want to you want her
to wait for 80 seconds you know you
never experienced it that hot hottest
water of your life even the people at
vesuvius who are stuck in coagulated
volcanic rock didn't experience anything
as hot as my last vegas water after 80
seconds okay
maybe you can control the bottom of your
sink where it's like the heat
you have to go through the
[Laughter]
pompeians that
you